if you want to do great things you need
to be surrounded by greatness you're the
product of your environment it holds you
where you are until you change your
environment you won't change the results
you're getting so put this on in the
background as you do your work and soak
up some great wisdom from some great
people we think we ain't about how hard
you hit how do you succeed if you don't
try the time is now to be great you
gotta love it you gotta have a passion
you really can make what you want
there's a choice we have to make as
people as individuals if you want to be
great at something you have to make the
inherent sacrifices that come along with
that family time hanging out with your
friends said the age of 18 I knew that I
was not going to be stopped this was my
life we all can be masters at our craft
but you have to make sacrifices that
come along with making a decision
my favorites are on the album is man in
the mirror oh yeah I like that that's
that's my favorite song I tend the whole
I feeling that no matter what you do in
the world it really has to start with
you is my philosophy too if you want to
make the world a better place take a
look at yourself and then make a change
um it's all you do yeah well people
don't look at themselves honestly they
don't look at themselves and point the
finger at there's always the other guys
fought or somebody off you should change
yourself look at yourself make better of
yourself huh you know there's this myth
that that people think they don't need a
business plan and oftentimes I find
business owners who have an idea a great
one and where they miss it is the
execution they don't go through the
process of writing things down because
anytime you can take pen to paper and
write out your ideas and share them with
other people and get feedback which is
essentially a business plan you're going
to do better it could be a whiteboard in
an office it could be notes taken on
your computer or in a journal but I want
it to start with something that says
here's what my product or services
here's how I'm going to attack the
market here's how I'm going to beat the
competition here's how I'm going to
learn from my competitors here's what
I'm going to take from my customers and
here's the kind of people I need to
surround myself with if you don't answer
those questions then really you're just
kind of like a like a dodgeball game
just going to go out there and wing it
and at some point you're gonna get
whacked on the side of the head I
believe having a clear vision of where
you want to go and and being able to
articulate that to yourself perhaps
writing it down I tend to I take out the
the notes section of my iPad and and
will will write down what it is I want
to accomplish and think about precisely
what I hope to accomplish with a
particular assignment so I'll write that
down so having a clear objective i think
is important i think we control our own
destiny and so whether David makes it or
not has nothing to do with sort of the
size of the might of Goliath and if
you're thinking like that you'll
probably always be able to find a reason
and frankly an excuse in some lame
answer as to why you can't win because
the markets aren't good I was in the
middle of this and you know through 2000
in the first crash and people are go on
its markets terrible markets terrible
like I'm selling stretchy t-shirts not
nothing to do with the financial crisis
it's like sports are going to be played
and kids will wear it or they won't and
you know I think anybody can you can
look and find but I challenge all of us
to say stop finding reasons to find and
make excuses that you know we
affectionately done our mccall loser
talk and I don't know you you've got to
just will it and and focus on on making
habit once you have passionate thing
that you're passionate about now you can
look at other people or other entities
or other things or works of art you can
draw things from that to help you be
better at what you buy looking for those
common denominators which I wanted to
know how do I prepare her how do I
prepare how do I study how do i view the
game how do you build your game and my
response is much like the way he builds
products and you think sequentially oh
yeah you look at this the end result of
what you want to create but in order to
create that there's so many other little
things that go into this massive entity
that or device it's no different than
building my basketball game you start
with we want your game to be what we
make your game most unstoppable or hard
to deal with and now you work backwards
from there and you start building it one
piece at a time one move at a time one
counter it so there's a lot of
similarities there
get to the prime gentleman has to put it
up in the buzzer
the Lakers
my purpose oh boy I think to give in the
best way I can through song and through
dance and through music I mean I am
committed to my art I believe that all
art has as this ultimate goal the union
between the material and the spiritual
the human and the divine I believe that
to be the reason for the very existence
of art and I feel I was chosen as an
instrument to just give music and love
and harmony to the world you know cash
flow to me is is important but working
capital from the beginning is also
important I find that people come to me
with a projection about their business
it's a brand new idea they think they're
going to make money in six months they
don't make money in six months and then
I'll have a back-up plan they don't have
a reserve they don't have a line of
credit and so they go out of business
and that's probably the single biggest
reason small businesses closed not
because the idea is terrible now because
they have bad people it don't have the
sufficient amount of working capital
hear the expression all the time you
know the grass is greener on the other
side of the fence but don't forget you
can only make the grass greener on your
own side of the fence you can't change
the color of the grass over there you
could only change the color of the fence
on your side and so the real issue is
where's the best opportunity where can
you find opportunities in your life
where's our an opportunity for instance
to start a new business I i I've met a
lot of entrepreneurs who started
businesses and most folks think that
they're going to sit down in their study
and think and think and read magazines
and trying to find some opportunity that
that'll allow them to become rich by
starting a business I haven't found a
lot of people do that most of the people
that I have found that we're successful
in starting a business of their own
looked around them in the job they
already had and and looked for
opportunities that weren't being filled
by their their current enterprise looked
for customer needs that weren't being
met look for something that this wasn't
working particularly well there's a
saying it was actually attributed to the
chairman of so
several years ago and it said that
perfection is the enemy of innovation
perfection is the enemy of innovation
and what that effectively means is that
how many entrepreneurs are sitting out
there with a great idea tinkering in
their garage right now waiting to get
this concept out there waiting to get
the idea out there but it's not quite
perfect yet the criteria that we use an
Under Armour whenever we look at a
product or whatever we decide to do
something is that it must be better than
what's currently available in the market
it may not be the perfect vision of what
we have but sometimes you have to get in
the game in order to make it improve
don't ever settle don't ever let a
product just be okay or just barely good
enough but I challenge all of us to
think in that way as you could well you
just got to have the the fearlessness to
really take those shots you know because
you missed those shots then you have to
deal with the criticism you have to deal
with us talking about it right right
right so you know a lot of times a lot
of people kind of get a little
apprehensive about taking the shots
because of that while we mentioned some
but you start smiling away just thinking
it out the word yeah well it's it's
always it's always been a myth to me as
to why certain people don't really like
those situations because of the the
pressure at you know because we've all
lost games before so it's not like by
you missing a shot you about to face
something that you will never face again
or having faced in the past you know I
mean we've all come up short it's you
know one time or another so just got to
kind of let it all hang out and you
don't trust your skills and trust the
work that you put in
now try it again out between the Rings
guarded by tripping Kobe on the move
lobs for O'Neal
I remember having the guys go back in
and create more innovative this we don't
this is our thing we don't a lot of
sounds on the album that are found from
keyboards that are you know pretty much
programmed into the Machine and
throughout and make our own down mm-hmm
get on things we beat on things so
nobody can duplicate what we do we make
them with our own hands we find things
and we create things and that's the most
important thing to me to be a pioneer be
an innovator one of the things that I do
do before I go to bed at night is that
make a quick list of the things that I
know I have to deal with the next day
and I try to get those knocked out
before noon because from noon on it's
kind of like the wild wild west I don't
know what's going to happen I don't know
what new issues going to come up and so
you want to really be smart about your
time to knock out the things that you
have to who do I have to talk to what do
I have to review what do I have to do
with a bank or an employee or one of the
businesses you want to get out what I
would call the housekeeping you get the
housekeeping done in the morning and
then you get to kind of go farm the
fields for the rest of the day and part
of the challenge or part of the
challenge for me at least is that that
lines get very blurry of when the day
actually shuts off and that can present
a real challenge to you know your
personal life and your friends and in
kind of that balance so it's it's hard
but the first part of my day is the
focus to all the occupations I've had
I've experienced successes and as you
know failures I'm asked what it felt
like to lose to President Obama not as
good as winning failures aren't fun but
they are inevitable more importantly
failures don't define who you are some
people measure their life by their
secular successes how high on the
corporate ladder they got how much money
they made did they do better than their
high school classmates if that's the
kind of success you're looking for
you're bound to be disappointed
life has way too much chance in
serendipity to be assured fame or
fortune leadership is required it's in
the word it's to lead and it's lead by
example and it's haven't set a vision
and all those kind of things that you
need but it's to make sure that you
never limit the idea or the opportunity
you know what I find myself doing more
often than not is ensuring that we have
enough runway in front of us and sharing
that we are thinking about things big
enough because you can come complacent
your job is to push your company but
it's not just to show up and say I want
twenty percent more more important you
need to set an expectation and set a
path in a vision that allows people to
achieve that at the same time so that
means taking things using things in your
life that are scars using those moments
as a weapon right using those as using
basketball is kind of like a vehicle
through which to express yourself right
so it doesn't so at that moment for us
to face the Celtics again it's not about
the Celtics it's not about your opponent
it's about you it's about you taking it
and it struggles and channeling that
through the game right as it as a way to
to unleash right so now I became a
matter of how do i express that to them
how do I get them to that point where
they figure this out for themselves cuz
I can't say hey listen I need you to
play harder so what you did well I had
to share my story I had to open up to
them and let them know I've dealt with
things this is the things that I use
this is how i go about focus this is how
I deal with adversity this is how I deal
with you know arguing with my wife the
day of the game is showing up to the
game and still having that focus to be
able to play like I used those things to
open up with them and then in turn they
were able to to take those stories and
and make them their own
the lakers because this man kobe
bryant's take over
sue is elbow into the basket that time
okay what's going through your mind when
you're dancing not thinking thinking is
the biggest mistake a dancer could make
you have to feel you become the face you
become a fanfare you become the clarinet
and flute in the strings and the drowns
so you're almost a physical embodiment
amusing absolutely
you need to have a life coach you need
to have someone who'll tell you the
truth tell you that the perfect mate
you've been looking for is no more
perfect than you are tell you when
you're wrong tell you what you need to
do to make things right I can assure you
that finding someone who cares enough
about you to tell you the truth and then
is willing to take time to give you
their counsel and their coaching that's
invaluable look for it I can remember
those early days when you want to be big
you're constantly projecting yourself as
a company you're going to be and whether
it was 1996 and we're starting out with
seventeen thousand dollars in revenues
and you've got that you know we're going
to beat those those bad guys whatever
your industry is whoever the big one you
can point it and it's it's good to have
a nemesis Luke Skywalker wouldn't be him
if you didn't have Darth Vader and so
you needed a side and define who's your
Darth Vader and then you typically put a
put them over the dartboard you throw
darts at them you think about them but
you understand that in order if you'd be
successful it's got nothing to do with
anybody else and frankly the games that
we all are typically playing or not
zero-sum games either and so in order
for us to win which is still part of the
ethos and philosophy we take it under
armour today it's not a matter
necessarily of someone else losing in
sporting goods the pie was about this
big and you'd look and people were
constantly trying to take sheriff from
each other back and forth and when we
got into it and the thing that allowed
us for our breakthrough was we
effectively went and made our own pie
and with that we created this new
category and it gave us the legs to
think about not necessarily how we
compared to somebody else but the
opportunity that we had I think when
comparing what we were doing versus
compared to what we felt the opportunity
was well you just got to put one foot in
front of the other and you know
sometimes I think here you for myself
it's easy to become distracted a little
bit and start trying to look at the
Pinal with the final pictures don't look
like
and you know when you do that you can
you can easily become frustrated with
where you are at the moment so you know
my advice is just to focus on each day
and now you have a plan in place of how
you want to improve and how you want to
get better and you stick to that plan
and trust the fact that you know every
day that you you know stick to the plan
I'll get you to you and result
by Kobe Bryant believe in yourself study
the greats and become greater no matter
what I don't care if the whole world is
against you or tease your so you're not
going to make it believe in yourself no
matter what about what some of the
greatest men that made a mark on this
world we're treated like that you know
you know you're not going to do it
you're not going to get anywhere they
laughed at the Wright brothers and let
the Thomas Edison they laughed at Walt
Disney they made jokes up in before they
said he was a nerd you didn't have a
college degree as he dropped out of
school isn't dropped out of school they
took forward to court to prove his
intelligence that's not really me yeah
and he's a minute shaped and changed our
culture our customs when you live we do
think I say follow your passion which
should be sports I say if you have a
passion for business you also better
have a knowledge for it and so if people
want to own a business they better have
worked for somebody else for a while and
they better have an intrinsic knowledge
of that industry and so it would be like
me getting into you know the barber
business and I never went to learn how
to cut hair I shouldn't have a knowledge
if I don't have the knowledge then I
better have a partner or I better have a
manager or a leader in place who's
vested in the business who does have a
knowledge and so three guys want to open
up a restaurant because they think it's
cooled open up a restaurant but none of
them not to cook or suede tables they
shouldn't be in that business my path in
life has primarily been focused on doing
things I thought were fun and enjoyable
and so that was fun I mean my my
undergraduate major was English I was it
why would you go into English what I
mean there's no future right as an
English major what are you gonna do all
right and and but I like reading and I
liked writing so when I took English is
my major and then coming out of business
school in law school I wanted a
consulting because I enjoyed it not
because that's where I thought I'd spend
my life I expected that I'd be there for
two or three years like most people do
and then get a job in a in a line
corporation of some kind and and and
perhaps move up more aggressively by
having started in consulting I love
consulting because I am I oriented
towards solving problems I like analysis
and data and problem solving and writing
and writing presentations that's what I
like to do that's what took me there and
so i would i would go to those i
followed the career path that you enjoy
most as opposed to trying to follow a
career path that you think will will
lead to the highest income or the quick
quickest promotion do what you enjoy and
and then your life will be enjoyable and
fulfilling i was lucky enough to not
listen to people i was lucky enough to
use this statement that i framed by
thinking back then and hopefully still
today i was always smart enough to be
naive enough to not know we could not
accomplish i was always smart enough to
be naive enough to not know we could not
accomplish why not us because anybody's
smart i talked to said are you crazy
you're going to go against these
behemoths in this industry you know how
big these other brands are the guys out
west the guys in germany it's a
dangerous category the fact is i didn't
care all I knew is that I was going to
make the world's greatest t-shirt and it
started out making the world's greatest
t-shirt for football players that
quickly grew to baseball players
lacrosse players hockey players on and
on and on great product always wins and
we are fortunate to have that most
important stay humble see the humbleness
that a child like a newborn baby had
even though you become powerful or or
have power with the people with your
talent with like you know with what
Michelangelo did was sculpting you know
underneath all that be as humble as a
child as a baby and its kind and giving
and loving ever become puffed up with
pride entrepreneurs who have authored a
product or a process that isn't working
today have to make the bold step of
reinventing themselves I talk about it
all the time how over the course of my
life whether it was at 12 years old or
18 years old or 25
or even today I'm constantly working to
reinvent myself I'm not any different
than a package on a shelf people have to
feel that it's relevant they have to see
the warning labels they have to
understand the contents it has to be
appealing it has to provide value to
people and so when an entrepreneur has a
product or a process that they've
authored and they're not willing to
change it then they're going to end up
like Circuit City or Montgomery Ward or
sears or Fiat or whatever these brands
are that don't exist anymore right every
single company in this country today if
they're not evolving they're dying and i
don't know why an entrepreneur would
think that they would be exempt from
that process I'm not interested in their
ego I'm not interested in their pride
i'm not interested in their feelings i'm
interested in their business being
successful and so i think not only does
their business have to do it but but we
as entrepreneurs have to do it as well
I'm going to draw off in my your account
from the life of the Savior to help me
describe what I believe is a secret to
abundant living you recall that Peter
and the other fishermen had been
unsuccessful in catching fish and the
master directed them to return to their
boats to go out deeper and to let down
their nets again which they did and when
they did so they were met with enormous
success these were the words the lucra
chords that the master spoke he said
this launch out into the deep and let
down your nets launch out into the deep
and let down your nets in some ways
these wards are a metaphor for life
launch out into the deep don't live in
the shallows live in the deep waters
grasp every ennobling experience is
available to you embrace every dimension
of living that challenges you that
educates you that elevates you live for
purpose is greater than yourself lose
yourself in the service of others reach
beyond the shallowness of selfishness
and complacency and mindless conformity
and of indulgence
this is the promise launch out into the
deep and your nets will be filled and so
the hardest thing that any organization
has is getting the people right right
and so I've been very fortunate because
the first decision that I made was to
hire my first partner which was Kip
Fulks right and getting Kiptyn and then
I trusted that you know Kip would hire
two great people and they would hire
three great people and are not all along
the way you know you get to establish
and you get to build a culture and you
know that's something that takes a long
long time to do and it's something that
you better be good at because you're
never done particularly in a growing
company is everybody wants to compete I
think it's knowing how to compete and
also you know I um you know true
competitive instinct really kicks in
when you're down you know like I said a
lot of people were competitive and
things that are rolling their way and
you know things that they were naturally
good at nobody takes her true
competitive person when things are down
like this to really step up to the plane
graph through
what Kobe does best in that
which is sensational boy how do you
write a song how do i write a song well
you don't i sat down and had all right
what would happen if i SAT here and
played some chords whatever and say i'm
going to write the best song ever
written nothing happens something in the
heavens has to say look this is the time
that this is going to be late on you and
this is what I want you to have it now i
remember when i when i wrote Billie Jean
I was riding in my car down Ventura
Boulevard all I said to myself
beforehand I want to write a song with a
great base hook you know and and I just
let it go really and in several days
later you know about and I'm to do um
I'm do you know what hmm so did okay you
you were singing the baseline sing that
again and then what happened how did you
get the other instrumentation and the
composition how did it work it see the
thing is in artists seem to get in the
way of the music get out of the way of
the music you know don't write the music
let the music right itself
let's talk about the myth that your
product is already good enough people
often develop a new product and it's
fantastic and it hits the market like in
a blaze of glory and it sells and
there's back orders if you're delivering
them a good product or service today
they're still going to expect something
better tomorrow and the one thing you
have to worry about is there's a
competitor out there somebody they can
mimic your offering so you always have
to stay one step ahead of them and so
when products don't morph into something
new they don't develop into something
better and smarter and faster and less
expensive it's probably the biggest
takeaway less expensive then people are
going to find alternatives for me I'd
like to go out and study the competition
that's how I reinvent myself I go out
and I study businesses aren't exactly
the same but they run their business
with a set of ethics and a set of
principles that are second to none and
they can be in a space that's completely
different than mine but I learned
something from them I don't think we do
that enough I did something to keep
things in perspective to keep myself
grounded at the top of a sheet of paper
that was always placed on the podium so
we could make notes during the debate
just before the debate kicked off I
wrote at the top one word dad I also
drew a small image of the Sun and
throughout the debate when I glanced
down at that paper to look at my notes
that I'd taken I was reminded of my
father's fearlessness in fighting for
what he believed was right and the son
that reminded me of course of that
familiar scripture let your light so
shine we don't lose that debate I hoped
I would never do anything that would
dishonor or discredit the things I hold
most dear now during your life you're
going to encounter circumstances that
make you sweat for many of you the exams
and tests won't be over when you
graduate and you're all going to stand
at podiums stand in front of a boss to
ask for a raise or work on some critical
project in your employment that will
make a big difference in your life at
moments like those perspective is a very
powerful friend you can welcome
perspective through preparatory prayer
by considering the blessings of the
temple or by simply glancing at your CTR
ring find ways to keep your life in
perspective I would tell you that the
number one key to under armour success
to any new company success plain and
simple is focus and the thing in lost in
sort of the first ten years that we
don't get credit for at under armour was
that from 1996 to really 2000 we had one
product great entrepreneurs take one
product and say we're going to be great
for this and most importantly we're
going to be famous for one thing and
that is like the greatest advice I can
give you because so often you get caught
up with trying to keep up with the
Joneses and going but they're doing this
and they're doing that it's like they're
also like 150 times your size you're not
in the same league you need to become
great at one thing and that's where
under armour when the first five years
it was we're today we're on I think it's
over the 60th different iteration of
that first short sleeve wicking
compression t-shirt that I made and so
often you see people going you've got to
make a long sleeve you've got to make
one for women's you've got to make one
here it was like I have to make this
product great and we literally sold it
and made it and made it over and over
and it was never frankly done and that's
what allowed us from that t-shirt and
like you should make shoes you should
make shoes you should make shoes and I'm
going we're not ready to make shoes and
it wasn't until two thousand six when we
finally launched shoes 10 years into our
company and then frankly it's not even
really until now and getting better ten
years after beginning to make them and
eight years after selling them where I
think we're really beginning to see
scale in the ability to be great in
Footwear and it took us becoming famous
and one thing first before you just
start running off on a number of ideas
that aren't the most important thing to
you know the success of your business I
was of utmost importance like I'm was
such a die-hard fan Laker fan growing up
man and just my personality like it was
for me to ask for trade
to go play someplace else to try to
chase a championship that's not me man
that's not being that's not what my
career has been about that's not who I
am I stay with it stuff that I've been
through in my life and then from in my
career and just taught me anything is
the fact that you'll have good moments
and bad moments have great moment you
have horrible moments you just keep
going through all of them and then
things work themselves out then you got
a good event obtained two directions
you talk about elevation cheering up
Raptors people eat inside again put
somebody or the poster I mean with any
type of creation you create what's
inside of you subconsciously what
influences you I'm a fantasy fanatic and
anything that take you off into another
world escapism that's what I like um I'm
not so crazy about the reality of
everything I like a lot of fantasy and
that's where I try to create to get away
to become moved become how many people
you meet at a party or at a restaurant
to tell you they're entrepreneurs and in
the past I used to say no does that mean
you don't work mmm and so an
entrepreneur to me is is kind of a
nonsensical word you're either a
business owner or you are a team member
one of the two and I think being a
business owner is the hardest thing to
do in this country you take your money
hopefully not your mother's money but
you take your money and you invest in an
idea which is essentially investing in
yourself but if you do it solely to make
money you're going to lose and you
really have to do it and I know that a
lot of people out there get up every
morning in the household okay and
they're driving in the car right now and
they're on the way to a job that they
may not love yeah and I would encourage
them just to stick to the grind get the
paycheck pay the bills learn learn and
learning too many young kids out of
college tell me they're entrepreneurs
and I tell them you can't be an
entrepreneur until you've worked for
somebody else and you know what it feels
like to be fired right to be called on
the mat or to be harassed or to be
mismanaged you got to know what that
feels like so that when you're on the
other side yeah you can be respectful to
people yep if you're spending all your
time in one aspect of your life and not
devoting it to other things that are
important to you then obviously things
are out of whack a couple of things I
backed into your in the joint program
business law program I I came from
Brigham Young University to Harvard and
was convinced i would flunk out and
because I looked around I saw these
people who were obviously smarter than
me and and how as I possibly going
make it in this environment except by
just studying like crazy and so I
studied all the time and if I was not
studying I felt like there's this black
cloud hanging over me i should be
studying I've got to be working because
I'm going to flunk out and and it was
omnipresent at some point I finally said
you know what I'm gonna do something
which which goes back to biblical times
I'm gonna take sunday off I'm gonna
decide i'm not going to study at all on
sunday and i'm gonna devote that day to
my family to worship and just personal
time and it was amazing what happened
when i made that decision because then
on that sunday i didn't feel the black
cloud there anymore it's like okay I I
can't study today I don't have to worry
about it and and the same thing happened
as as i went into my career in the
consulting industry I said you know what
I'm just not going to work when i come
home at the end of the day it may be a
late night and maybe i get home at six
or seven instead but when I come home
I'm going to close my brief brief case
and that work and I'm going to devote
the time I have at home to my family and
it was wonderful it was just it was it
was freeing because I could really focus
on the things that I cared most about in
life which was for my wife and my kids
you know speed and the ability to make
fast decisions you know smarts is
something you never want to turn your
your back on but if I had to choose I
would probably take speed especially in
starting a business and being an
entrepreneur and there's so many great
ideas right now that are sitting in a
basement or attic where the
entrepreneurs just timid or afraid to
get out to market because they think
it's not perfect it's not right it's not
ready to go and one thing you learn in
business is that version 2 is always
going to do that of the version 1 you
can say I want to wait I want to hold
back I'm just not ready but to go and to
move forward and I've had to make
decisions as a company that I didn't
believe we're always the perfect
decisions but I believe they were
probably the best decisions for us as a
company and us as a brand
and sometimes that better decision is
just making a decision I've always had
some our best performances on a roll
fans
actually we love it problem
they don't understand who I
not only am i comfortable being an
outsider that has become a source of
motivation so when I go to these places
and you yeah sure comforts me yeah
they'd love to get into Nash's hand and
they do
a one point game
prayin for the
I think what they get for me I get from
them I told I've said it many times my
greatest inspiration comes from kids
every song I write every dance I do all
the poetry I write is all inspired from
that level of innocence that
consciousness of purity and children
have that I see God in the face of
children and man I just love being
around it that all the time you know I
have a terrible fear that I lay awake at
night with that's the fear of failure
and the embarrassment that comes with it
and so people like to have a lot of
pride and say you know I'm not
embarrassed I'm not I think anybody
that's an entrepreneur deep down really
deep down in their soul has fear of
failure what will people say what will
people think and it's hard it's a hard
challenge and so I try to ignore it as
much as I can but I I find it kind of
haunting me and so I push through
because I really believe that I have an
obligation to keep trying and trying and
trying and I've had plenty of failure in
my life what happened was when I turned
35 and 2008-9 happened I became much
more comfortable with admitting my
vulnerability acknowledging my mistakes
saying when I was wrong showing my cards
and saying I was stupid crumbs could be
one of those situations where I tried to
outsmart something and no I don't think
it's going to fail but I have to be
realistic it could anything I do could
fail your job will expand your skills it
will demand your ability your energy and
your time hard work ennobling work dive
into your profession with passion and
hearts go beyond what's expected or
required and in doing so by the way you
will learn the secret to advancement and
that is doing your present job well that
it is absolutely in any good company
there must be a fight like family
mentality where you sit at that table
every idea is out there and whether it's
me pushing them because I'm trying to
get my company ready for the scale of
growth that we're about to see and
trying to prepare and get yourself in
front of that because many of you will
be faced where typically in any business
your one is lagging the other I say one
is that you sort of front-end you have
back end and there's this constant
natural tension between people saying
with all the facilities we can't do it
we have to and i'm one of those that
believes in like you've got to sell it
first you've got to push it and we're
going to figure out how to make it we're
going to figure out how to get there and
there's times where we've gotten too big
on the other side but the bigger box the
bigger warehouse you build your
typically filling it with stuff you
don't need if there's any two things
going to kill you in business it is
people and it is inventory and be
incredibly sensible to both of them and
for the entrepreneurs in here that may
be in a fund raise or going in a fund
raise or thinking about a fundraising
it's the worst thing i think i see is
company's new companies that become
perpetual money razors if you need money
why don't you do yourself a favor you
keep the equity and if you need money go
sell the stuff in your warehouse go sell
your product and if you can't sell your
product then there's probably something
wrong with the business because there's
nothing more fundamental than is someone
willing to take cash out of their pocket
and put it in your hand and receive your
good and if you can't answer that
question of does your product sell you
need to have a faster conversation and
he gets to the gym at four thirty in the
morning to see Kobe just drenched in
sweat like you jumped in a pool and then
Kobe wants to make and do conditioning
and waits for a couple hours so then
when the trainer goes to sleep after a
few hours you coming back to the gym at
like
11am and he sees that Kobe never left
the gym at all because he had to make
sure that he made eight hundred shots
before he left after he's been working
out for hours and hours like you think
this is new to me this is an excerpt
from Shaq's book talking about Kobe well
they had a feud so he says he was so
young and so immature in some ways but I
can tell you this everything Kobe is
doing now he told me all the way back
then he was going to do it we were
sitting on the bus once and he told me
I'm going to be the number one scorer
for the Lakers I'm gonna win five or six
championships and I'm going to be the
best player in the game and I was like
okay whatever then he looked me right in
the eye and said I'm going to be the
will smith of the NBA Shaq used to say
he would catch Kobe Bryant on the gym
and the court without a ball practicing
place this is who he is it's just
ingrained in him to do whatever we can
for a slight edge and Shaq said this
this is funny looking but you know what
it probably helped a lot of people want
to they say that they're gonna do
something Kobe Bryant does it right talk
is cheap but Kobe did it because he
competes with himself every single day
he wants more out of himself every
single day it's that competitive drive
to be the best that carries it carries
him through practices it carries him
through the weight training sessions
conditioning making sure that he gets
800 shots every day carries him to work
on his craft when no one is watching
away from elgin baylor record well
there's seven beat every
the 81-point game ladies and gentlemen
you have witnessed the second greatest
story fulfilled
screw you have something within your
records that everybody just loves why i
can say i just created an honor to the
public in your what i do i couldn't
explain why the anatomy of why it
happens there's a formula not that i
know of i is my heart i put my heart in
it you put your heart in yeah but
Michelangelo no I know the Creator will
go but its work survives that is my to
escape I 10 divided my soul
I can't find all
just keep calm I think what do you put
into it well whatever I think that's not
really mean I can sing a song I don't
say it if i don't mean it I go through
thousands and thousands of applications
and sometimes I pick businesses that are
new and innovative and the products
exciting and sometimes I pick businesses
that are pretty ordinary when its
ordinary and it's saturated biggest
challenges you're now dealing with the
commodity and so whether it's a coffee
shop or a yogurt shop the question is is
the product relevant in the marketplace
and if it's saturated can you rise to
the top of the list I want to encourage
people not to run away from saturated
markets but I want you to run away if
you don't have the time the resources
the energy the people the process or the
attention to detail to be best in class
and so if you're going to open up a
coffee shop in a very crowded market you
better have something that's unique it
better be experiential your product
better be amazing your process better be
on point and the people that sell it
better be better in product knowledge
and better and experience than anything
else I guess a different way to look at
it is if you go into an industry that's
not saturated you should probably ask
yourself is there a reason that nobody
else is in this I can't be the only
person with this idea and so you get
into a business that's not saturated it
may tell you that there's not really a
market there I think I'd like to get
into the hangar business I mean is it
saturated is it not is there a reason
that everybody is not in it I don't
really mind whether it's saturated or
not I have to like the product it has to
be relatable and it has to be not
totally recession proof but it has to be
kind of recession proof I think it's
important that if you're going to get
into a business and you're thinking
about taking your last fifty thousand
dollars in getting it getting into
something you better have something that
is unique if it's going to be a
commodity and you better better make
sure that you really understand what
happens when the economy goes up and
down and study those trends each of you
here will influence other
I think of that perhaps you'll shape
history perhaps you'll shape one
person's history consider with care how
you act what you say and to what you're
going to vote your life to because I
assure you your choices will shape the
lives of other people if you are sitting
on an idea whether it's on your laptop
whether it's in your garage whether it's
in your basement whether it's in the
back of your car give it a shot right
and the best advice I ever received find
out if your product and sell don't let
anybody talk you out of it give it a
chance try make it happen this is our
greatest asset as a nation and one that
we have to continue to encourage you
don't have to go broke you don't have to
bet everything on it but you can start
one day at a time taking a chance and
seeing if you too can build a great
company thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what you think
of the video please leave a comment and
let me know I hope you do something
great today continue to believe and I'll
see you soon